she's gotta be grateful now on with her
on the ground it was just obscene
Masseria tested all everyday for me
going over there of a Freelander for
Walter motors and then there was the
alarm bells and the message come over
the channel it come outside and I just
couldn't believe your eyes it's just
absolutely devastating there's such an
aggressive fire exhaust they are just
spreading through the cars and explosion
after explosion and it was just you know
just very very very disturbing really
yeah just take us through how you first
became aware of this plane crash were
you aware of it before or did the plane
show any signs of being in trouble did
you were just you were you just alerted
when the plane was there on the ground
crashed and the smoke billowing out well
I was in the reception which has like a
large glass glanced at the front and the
mist over the channel would say everyone
evacuate the building and you could just
tell by just the way the guy was talking
on the channel that it wasn't a fire
drill and as soon as I turned around I
could see through the glass balls just
oj me because he looked sort of the one
of the wings sticking up and it was just
been frames and and this time they were
sort of four or five cars around all
that flak but that faster spread like I
say after sort of ten or twelve minutes
a fire brigade got there they they
managed to get on top of me quickly
which was very fortunate because at one
stage you almost felt like it was just
going to I was gonna rip across the
whole car apart yeah because the
pictures you're just showing there which
you filmed earlier I mean the smoke is
really thick it seems to be spreading
very rapidly the fire so that that swift
action probably did did averse a lot
more damage well yeah that was actually
quite early as well that's just still
what is in issues they see one fire
engine in the pictures which was the a
small fire engine which came from the
airfield itself the fire got a lot more
aggressive after that until the the fire
end is absolute evolved which I have got
some photos off each other
I will then email into you can show
people but there yeah just devastating
obviously any thoughts go out to
everybody on the plane and everything
them I say just saying god nobody on the
ground was hurt and you Thomas thank you
very much
to us here at Sky News tonight